while I was
there the the famous Halloween costume
controversy took place
where that really fast of the yeah I've
uh I've pulled that clip actually
because I want you to reflect on how
this uh informed your your worldview the
Halloween costume controversy was that a
letter uh had gone out um uh suggesting
you know us um suggesting culturally
sensitive Halloween costumes and some of
the faculty had objected to the idea
that administrators would uh tell uh
college students who are adults what is
appropriate to wear for Halloween um and
one of those people was uh Erica
christakis whose husband Nicholas
christakis uh was a sort of a dean of
Housing and he was confronted by a bunch
of angry students who thought that
administrator should dictate or you know
set some parameters for what is and
isn't a Halloween costume and this is a
clip from that confrontation provided by
uh fire uh the uh free campus Free
Speech group so let's uh play that
clip quiet for all soulman you
understand that as your position of
matter is your job to create a place of
comfort and home for the students that
live in silan you have not done that by
sending out that email that goes against
your position as Master do you
understand that no I don't agree with
that then then why the [__] did you
accept the position who the [__] hired
you I have a different Vision you should
step down if that is what you think
about being a master you should step
down uh how did so you so you were you
were on campus when all that drama
unfolded how did that not
only Not only was I on campus but a I
actually saw a part of that interaction
unfold from across the street because I
lived in the Residential College across
the street from Solon uh and B I was the
opinion editor of the Yale Daily News
which meant that
I uh not only had to solicit and edit op
EDS from Angry students uh upset about
all the systemic racism allegedly
permeating Yale but I also had to write
the paper official
editorial uh about the protests and the
way the editorial process worked was
that it was basically just a democratic
vote by the the editorial board um and
then the opinion editor had to kind of
execute the will of the editorial board
and write the the the oped even if the
opinion editor didn't agree with the
will of the editorial board and as
happened in this case right um you know
I'm not actually sure it was
meaningfully a democratic vote because
we got into the meeting to discuss
things and it it became clear within
seconds that anyone who dissented was
going to get called racist and shouted
down so nobody did even though I think a
lot of people privately thought this was
going too far they didn't say anything
you didn't
either it was it was very clear that
like if I had I sort of I tried to
gently push back on something but it was
quite clear that had I pushed it too far
it would have just evolved and the
outcome would have been the same but
even worse uh and so I kind of made a
tactical decision all right like you
know I'm not going to win this fight so
the best I can do is sort of try to
moderate whatever we end up writing
um so I had to actually write a fawning
editorial saying oh my God these
protesters are so brave and you know why
does the University you know should
listen to their pain blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah and then when I
tried to even sneak in a line about Free
Speech uh what happened was it was being
there was like a Google doc that was
that was effectively being uh stealth
not stealth edited But like everyone was
looking at the Google Doc so then I
throw in the line and people come over
to me and say I think this sounds you
know like you're blaming the protesters
how could you and then that line gets
taken out so it was it was a [__] show
it was terrible sitting keyboard just
sweating WR you know carefully writing
these sentences as if people are
watching the Google duck that's pretty
I'm not joking that is what happened and
uh look it was it was it was a preview
of what happened to the New York Times
and other big media outlets in 2020
media Outlets that of course employ a
lot of alums of the Daily News and the
Harvard crimson and other such did this
did this radicalize you this is the
origin story
I I I you know radicalize is a bit of a
strong word because I it's not like it's
not like I was a normal I mean I was
kind of a moderate Democrat it was just
pro- Free Speech but but you know it's
not like I was went from moderate
Democrat to you know fire breathing Maga
or anything like that but yeah it it it
made me much more concerned about who
the Future Leaders of the country would
be um I it definitely pushed me right
and subse developments after college
further pushed me right um but yeah this
was sort of a inflection point maybe
maybe radicalization too strong but
certainly an inflection point in my
political trajector well so I came to
college in 2014 same time as you and I
think for me the environment there was
extraordinarily radicalizing to the
point that it even inspired me one could
say to graduate early which was not my
plan to do so because I just had a
miserable time on campus I went to the
College of William and Mary and to set
the stage for um old geezers like Zack
and uh our viewers and listeners who
might not know you know 2014 was a weird
time it was right after um I guess the
officer who had uh stood accused of
killing Michael Brown had been acquitted
there were all of these riots related to
Ferguson Ferguson was basically on fire
sort of a precursor to the George Floyd
summer 2020 protest obviously we've seen
these um bubbling UPS of the protest
movement surrounding cop killings and
police brutality in the United States
this was not the first incarnation of it
uh and it was also not the last one but
2013 2014 was a very hot time for that
type of thing and so I recall that fall
being really intense on campus for that
reason for all of the racial and police
brutality reasons and then Rolling Stone
published the now widely discredited a
rape on campus um rape H story that
basically describes and I think this was
talked about at many college campuses
you know I went to William and Mary and
obviously this had occurred on uva's
campus uh very very close by you know
lots of friends there and so I think it
made a huge Splash not just in that sort
of college microcosm but on other
campuses too because there was
essentially I think a little bit of this
precursor to me too happening where you
know suddenly these sort of twin issues
of race relations police brutality and
campus sexual assault and sexual
harassment were sort of
not exactly entering the public
Consciousness but certainly having this
huge moment and to be 18 years old and
to have these two issues where so many
people were saying hey you're either
with us or you're against us you're
either fired up about this or you're you
know an evil you know Trump tar didn't
exists yet but like an evil right-winger
um it very much made it so I think many
people were
were I don't want to say forced into
submission but very much given all of
the social incentives to believe what
the her beli believes to go with the
herd and to not their descent and I was
one of the people I was writing for my
college newspaper and dissenting from
this and a lot of activist really made
my life hell as a result it ended up
becoming very quickly apparent it was
made apparent quite quickly to me that
this would not actually be a healthy
thriving place of intellectual discourse
and I should just cut my losses and get
the hell out because being part of the
working world is so much better uh you
know being an actual journalist and
being able to engage more thoughtfully
with these things
but did you have a similar experience
like were you doing the exact same thing
that I was just a little bit
north yeah it was it was similar um I
one time when I was the opinion editor
of the paper I published a oped
criticizing migration to Europe which
was admittedly I think
a defensible but also pretty fire and
brimstone restrictionist take um on the
issue um but you know we published crazy
far-left things all the time uh that
were just
completely completely batshit so I
thought all right you know this is a
little over the top in the other
direction but that's fine you know he's
not calling for genocide or anything
like it's he's just saying that Europe
should stop accepting migrants because
they're destroying like the culture of
Europe and creating safety issues okay
it's a little much but you know he can
say that I published it and then a girl
came up to me in the coffee shop like in
public and started berating me for
publishing the oped
um and and to be honest I didn't care
that much because like what was this
girl going to do to me but but that that
I think gives you a sense of what the
climate was like um I was lucky that I
Yale had a good network of conservative
student groups especially this thing
called the Yale political union which
contains a lot of conservative political
parties and so I I was in one of those
and I kind of had a friend group that I
knew was not going to cancel me or
disown me um and in fact within that
friend group I was like the token lib um
so if anything they were like they'd be
like Aaron you know okay yeah it's nice
that you believe in free speech but
really what you should believe is that
we need a Catholic Monarch who will
suppress free speech in the interest of
creating you know Our Lady of Guadalupe
Empire from from North America to South
America or whatever like like it it
sounds it sounds like a joke but there
were actually people who believed that
um so you know they they all for me they
were like oh yeah you know you you you
think that maybe uh maybe Title 9 is
going a little too far right like oh you
know you think you're controversial well
wait till you hear what we believe um so
how were they treated on campus though
like like you're saying there were
people way Weir well because they had
the social group like they were fine
they also weren't as outspoken though
like they weren't writing their takes
committing them to paper I think people
probably knew that they were Catholic
and conservative but they they
typically I think we're pretty good
about just just knowing when and where
to to share that so yeah look I I I had
a similar experience although I would
say that I didn't feel as socially
isolated as I think some people felt and
I actually especially at Yale where
there is this kind of conservative
infrastructure you know I would probably
advise students to be a little less
afraid of getting cancelled because as
long as you have the friends who won't
cancel you like doesn't really matter
someone calls you a mean name on
Facebook it just should learn to get
over that um but yeah look these these
these universities often do have a very
cying climate for for free speech and I
do know people at other uh Elite schools
um where there was not I think as
healthy a network of dissident students
and at those
schools people who spoke out
really re you know based of a deep
social price um yeah no it's it's a it's
problem um and so and and you asked
earlier do I think there's anything to
the conservative critique while having
seen it up close I mean yeah you know
the you you really will see kids get
piled on for saying things that are if
anything way to the left of Fox News but
just not quite to the left of Bernie
Sanders and you know you don't see
anything like that Pyon um triggered by
students saying that rationality is a
tool white male oppression which someone
literally wrote almost exactly that in
an oped for me that I had to edit right
I was sitting next to the girl and
editing it with her line by line and the
thesis of the OP ED was that demands for
rational discourse are a way of policing
the emotionality of women of
color right like it's pretty crazy and
you know that was what you were expected
to say oh that's an important
perspective thank you so much for
writing the soet like no I mean come on
hey thanks for watching that clip from
our new show just asking questions you
can watch another clip here or the full
episode here new episodes drop every
week so subscribe to reent TV's YouTube
channel to get notified when that
happens or to the just asking questions
podcast on Apple Spotify or any other
podcaster